all right it's best bets time heading
into week five of the 2018 nfl regular
season last week i was able to crow
because i was 3-0 in the week three best
bets of course i made up for that in a
bad way by going 0 and 3 in week four
mds one one and one with his picks i
don't i look
it seems easy
but you know what it really is not easy
mds picking games against the spread
it really isn't it's been kind of an
interesting exercise you and i have been
picking games against each other
straight up now for
seven years on the site but this is just
the first year since
gambling is now legal in more places you
and i decided to do some against the
spread and we really are finding out how
good those
odds makers are you know the house wins
for a reason and that is they set those
lines in spots where you you think you
have a good pick and you're just off i
mean you found that out on monday night
the line actually moved you had the
chiefs minus five which was a loss if
only you had
chosen it uh later in the week when it
moved to chiefs minus three and a half
it would have been a win for you but
it's just it's just crazy how those
those point spreads they are tough to
beat there's not many people who
consistently beat the spread
and i actually thought it was a win
because i saw three and a half and you
reminded me that it was actually five
when we made the picks so i i uttered a
profanity a couple of times and then i
moved on moving right along to this
week's games mds you get the first pick
odd week that's you even week it's me
and the way this goes for anybody who's
tuning in for the first time we each
pick a team against the spread and we
can't pick the same team we can pick the
other team from the same game which
we've done at least once but we can't
pick the same team so mds you're up
first
well i was going through this week's
point spreads and i was kind of hoping
to find
an underdog i thought would win outright
and the truth is
i didn't find many but the one i decided
to go with is
the broncos
getting one point against the jets i
felt like the the broncos i think are a
better team than they've shown i thought
the way they played tough against the
chiefs uh showed me a little something i
think that case keenum he's missing
passes but i i still think case keenum
is actually a better quarterback than
most people think he is i don't think
sam darnold is ready for that pass rush
that the broncos bring with von miller
and company so i like the broncos
probably to win a close game outright
and any time i like a team that's
getting a point to win outright i'm
going to take them so take broncos plus
one as my first pick
yeah that was the first one on my list
as well and i agree with you i think the
broncos better than the jets right now
case keenum put a little bit too much
air under a pass to demaryius thomas
that would have been like a mini version
of the minneapolis miracle because the
broncos would have won that game if
keenum connects with thomas who was wide
open and we wouldn't have been talking
about patrick mahomes nearly as much the
next day we would have been talking
about case keenum pulling it off again
with late-game heroics when it looked
like it was over for the second time
since the minneapolis miracle he gets it
done but it wasn't to be but i agree
with you i think the broncos plus one at
the jets is a good play
there's a desperation game brewing just
about 100 miles from where i'm sitting
it's up the road in pittsburgh and the
falcons and the steelers get together
the falcons at one and three the
steelers won two and one it's a
desperation game for both teams the
steelers are giving three and i like the
steelers in a bounce back game
especially because the falcons have
never won in pittsburgh now they only
play there every eight years but they
still have never won in pittsburgh you
get them out of that dome they've been
in the dome for three straight weeks i
don't know what the weather's going to
be in pittsburgh but it's not going to
be dome conditions that field is not the
same quality that's for sure and i think
the steelers will stabilize the steelers
defense will be better it can't be much
worse the falcons defense is abysmal i
think the steelers will win this game by
more than three and it could it could
end up being a shootout between the
steelers and the falcons
yeah and i like your way of thinking as
well and i i kind of agree with
the idea that the steelers really have
their backs against the walls i mean if
if we go back and look at the pre-season
odds in the divisions the steelers
weren't just the favorites to win the
afc north they were the overwhelming
favorites to win the afc north according
to those preseason odds and now here
they are they're finding themselves way
down there with the browns behind both
the bengals and the ravens i agree with
you i think the steelers are going to uh
to to really come out
knowing they need a win and come out
playing well and i think you made a good
pick there but my next pick is another
team that i think is a little bit
concerned about where it sits in its
division and that's the packers i think
even though the packers beat the bears
in week one they have to be a little bit
concerned that the bears have now reeled
off three straight and the packers
cannot afford a division loss if they're
going to keep pace with the bears and i
don't think they'll have one
on sunday in detroit i like the packers
giving up one point to alliance team
that has just been way too inconsistent
we've seen the lions play extremely well
on a sunday night against the patriots
we've also seen them play extremely
poorly on a monday night against the
jets i thought last week
dak prescott found some of the soft
spots in that lions defense especially
late in the game throwing passes to
ezekiel elliott dak prescott wisely
stopped trying to go at darius slay
who's the lion's best cornerback and
started going at the lions linebackers
some of the guys on that lions defense
who aren't able to really hold up well
in coverage i think aaron rodgers can
exploit some of those same areas that
dak prescott did late in that cowboys
alliance game and i like the packers
minus one to beat the lions definitely
by more than just one point
all right the carolina panthers had week
five week four this is week five they
had week four off they had extra time to
get ready for this one they have been a
different team at home a much better
team at home they have the giants
limping in to carolina and the giants
have not looked great so far this year
the offensive and defensive lines not as
good as they need to be and i think with
extra time to get ready christian
mccaffrey coming into his own cam newton
still cam newton more time to fine-tune
the offense under new coordinator norv
turner i think seven
i think it should be higher than seven
anytime i look at a line and i say wow
it should be a lot higher than that that
tells me i think that team is going to
cover and i think the panthers are going
to cover i think the giants aren't quite
in the process of falling apart they're
just not nearly as good as we thought
they were going to be this year because
the line play
isn't where it was supposed to be and
when the giants have good line play on
both sides of the ball that's when
they're contenders and this year it just
doesn't seem like it's there
yeah and i agree with you there i don't
i don't think the giants are making the
kinds of plays on offense that they need
to make if they're going to keep pace
with a panthers offense that i think is
looking good so i think you made another
good pick but it's not
one of the ones i was going to pick
because my next pick is one i feel
pretty good about and that is picking
the 49ers but not so much picking the
49ers as picking against the cardinals
the 49ers are giving four and a half and
i just don't like that cargill's offense
whether it's sam bradford whether it's
josh rosen i think the result is going
to be the same that cardinals offense is
just not going to put many points on the
board and i like the 49ers giving four
and a half and i also like cj beathard i
think a little bit more than most people
do obviously it's a huge disappointment
to the 49ers that they lost jimmy
garoppolo for the season that that
almost feels like it kills their entire
season also feels like it could kill
some big nfl prime time games where they
kind of put the 49ers in prime time
during the meat of the schedule thinking
that jimmy garoppolo would draw eyeballs
but i think cj beathard might play a
little bit better than people are
expecting and make the 49ers kind of an
interesting team not a team that i think
is going to be a title contender not a
team that i think will beat the rams in
the nfc west but a team that i think
will be competitive playing some close
maybe more exciting games than people
are expecting and when they're playing a
bad team like the cardinals i think the
49ers should win pretty comfortably i
like the 49ers by more than four and a
half see that one scared me away because
josh rosen looked pretty good in his
first game with the cardinals last week
and they gave the seahawks everything
they can handle so i don't i don't want
to make any proclamations about the
cardinals under rosen just yet because
those first three losses not on him lost
four on him but it was a close one and
maybe maybe they could upset the 49ers
this weekend you started this with a
team that is an underdog that you think
will win straight out and i feel the
same way about my last pick for sunday
the vikings went into philadelphia in
january
14-3
including that game in their last five
they are one three and one and this is a
chance for the vikings with extra days
to get ready with clear flaws on defense
that should be fixable like not putting
a linebacker on a receiver with an
eagles team that still feels like a work
in progress on both sides of the ball
maybe feeling the aftermath of playing
into the super bowl and the the super
bowl congratulation tour after that and
maybe having a little complacency going
into the next season i feel like the
vikings understand that it's it's it's
on the line for them right now they've
got to get this win and i think they win
straight up i think they exercise a
demon or two and they lay the foundation
to go on a bit of a run here because
they've had the extra time because mike
zimmer knows the urgency and because the
offense mds or the vikings underrated
the offense has been great they should
have been blown out by the rams on
thursday night and they were still in it
late because kirk cousins has been great
this year when they need him to be
well and i'll tell you in a strange
sense
i enjoy at this time of year
a game where two teams that thought they
were super bowl contenders
both have two losses a one two and one
team against a two and two team it
sounds strange but i actually kind of
like this game more than i would like a
game between
two four and oh teams because a game
between two four and oh teams at this
point in the season you figured look
whoever loses still still probably a
playoff team still probably feels like
they have championship potential but boy
the loser of this vikings eagles game
they're really going to be feeling like
they're hurting uh to have three losses
through week five when they both these
two teams i think both
headed into the season thinking hey we
have every reason to believe we're gonna
be in the super bowl this year i think
this is a very interesting game
uh between the vikings and the eagles
because the loser i think really might
be kind of going into panic mode like
hey
we didn't think we were going to lose
three games all year and here we've lost
three games through week five so that's
a game i really have my eye on not so
sure i agree with you about it though i
think i kind of like the eagles in this
game but it's gonna be a fun one to
watch because both teams really feel
like their backs are against the wall
well and that's the thing you start
racking up losses in september and
october you can kiss a one seat or a two
seed goodbye and that may be where the
vikings or the eagles ultimately end up
if they lose that game and then it
becomes can we scratch and claw our way
to a wild card berth then you got to go
on the road it's far different than
getting a bye week being at home and and
having a chance to to advance to the
next round in front of a friendly crowd
all right mds let's see how this week
plays out all of our picks will be filed
and posted at profootballtalk.com
not against the spread
and uh we'll we'll see maybe maybe i'll
ping pong back to 3-0 from 3-0 to 0-3 to
3-0 we'll keep doing our best to provide
some insight when it comes to these
games against the spread mds thanks as
always for your time we'll do it again
next week
sounds good mike
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports